SPEAKER 1: Understanding
workload management in BigQuery
is key to making efficient
use of system resources
and optimizing performance.
In today's episode of
"BigQuery Spotlight,"
we're talking about jobs,
the reservation model,
and best practices for
managing and controlling
work in BigQuery.
So let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
A job is an action that
BigQuery runs on your behalf.
It can either be a query,
extract, load, or copy job.
When you're performing
actions in the console--
for example, writing a query
against one of your data sets--
BigQuery will go ahead and
create a job on your behalf.
Each job has an
associated user identity
that created the job, a
location or the region
where the job is
actually executed,
which must be the same
location as the data
that you're using in the job,
and a status, either pending,
running, or done.
Because jobs have the
potential to take a long time
to complete, BigQuery
executes them asynchronously,
meaning each job is
run independently
and you can execute
multiple jobs at a time
without needing to finish
the current job to move on
to the next one.
Since jobs are all doing
some computational work,
each job will need to use
some compute resources.
In BigQuery, a unit of
compute is called a slot,
which is essentially a worker.
A slot is made up of
CPU, RAM, and network.
BigQuery automatically
calculates how many
slots are required by
each job, depending
on the size of the data and
the complexity of the logic.
When BigQuery
executes a query, it
uses the query plan to
execute different aspects
at different stages.
Each stage of the
query may actually
use a different number of slots.
If there isn't a slot
available, BigQuery
may take longer to
finish the query
as it waits for one to free up.
Before we talk about how
different jobs consume slots,
let's talk about how you
can get access to slots.
As a reminder, BigQuery offers
two different pricing models.
First, there's on demand, where
you pay for the amount of bites
scanned in query jobs.
In this model, you get 2,000
slots in each BigQuery project.
Alternatively, there's
flat rate pricing,
where you purchase a
number of dedicated slots
for your workloads.
Flat rate customers
purchase slots
in the form of commitments
that are either annual,
monthly, or flex, which can be
canceled after just 60 seconds.
With the flat rate
model, you can
decide the amount of
slots you need available
for your team's
BigQuery usage, plus
you have predictable pricing.
Once you have
purchased a commitment,
you can split that
commitment into any number
of reservations.
A reservation is essentially
a bucket of slots
that you can allocate
to specific jobs.
For example, you might
have a BI reservation that
is used for all Business
Intelligence queries
and an ELT reservation
that is used for all Data
Transformation queries.
Once you have a
reservation in place,
you can create an
assignment, which
assigns those slots to
your whole organization,
a specific folder, or
even a single project.
Each level in the
resource hierarchy
inherits the assignment
from the level
above, unless you override it.
Now what's really cool
is that idle slots
are available for
other reservations
in your organization to use.
So if no one is
loading a dashboard,
the slots in your BI reservation
can be used for ELT jobs.
All slots available
to these resources
will be distributed fairly
among projects and then jobs
within those projects, meaning
if there is one query that
is being run in the project,
it will have the ability
to use all the available slots.
If there are two queries
that are being run,
then each will have access to
half of the slots, and so on.
So it's unlikely that
one resource-heavy query
will overpower the system
and steal resources
from other running queries.
When you create an assignment,
you specify the type of job
that the assignment
will be used for.
For example, query assignments
are used for query jobs.
Pipeline jobs, on
the other hand,
are used for extract,
copy, and load jobs.
And a quick side note on
this, by default, load, copy,
and export jobs are free and
use a shared pool of slots.
But BigQuery makes no
guarantees on available slots,
which is why you may want to
create a pipeline reservation.
When jobs are assigned
to a pipeline assignment,
they lose access
to that free pool,
so make sure that jobs
have enough capacity.
Otherwise, performance could be
worse than using the free pool.
Finally, there are also
ML_EXTERNAL assignments
for BigQuery machine
learning queries
that use external services.
Now let's consider
how these resources
fit within the broader
BigQuery resource hierarchy.
Commitments, reservations,
and assignments
are created within a
project, sometimes referred
to as the admin project.
Many organizations choose
to purchase all commitments
from a single project to
make it easier to monitor.
These resources also live
within a specific location.
Commitments will be billed
to the admin project,
but these slots
are available to be
used by any jobs within
the organization.
Reservations can be also applied
to the whole organization,
or to any other folder or
project, where they can then
be used by jobs that are
executed in that same location.
This means that you
might have queries
that were run in the
us-northeast-1 region using
slots that you purchased,
but other queries
in the same project that were
run in the us-multiregion
might be running on demand.
Now that you have
an understanding
of jobs and the reservation
model, let's see it in action.
Inside the BigQuery console,
I can purchase slots
from the Reservation page.
Here, I will go ahead and
purchase 1,000 flex slots
in the United
States multiregion.
Let's go ahead and confirm that.
Great.
Now, once I have
my commitment, I'm
able to create a reservation.
Here, I'll create
a reservation that
allocates 500 of my slots to
handle queries from my Business
Intelligence tool.
With my reservation in place,
I can create an assignment
that ties this
reservation to my project
where BI queries are run.
Now, when a query is
run in this project,
it will use slots
in my reservation.
To drill into this further,
I can use the job ID
to select the execution details
from the information schema.
Here, I can see which
reservation it used
and how many slots it used on
average throughout the stages
of the query execution.
Look out for an upcoming
video on BigQuery monitoring
where we'll go into detail on
how you can use the information
schema to understand
utilization and make decisions
around reservation sizes.
Amazing.
So now you know all about the
BigQuery reservation model.
Today, we talked about the
standard BigQuery reservation
model, but you may also
hear the term reservation
when digging into BI Engine,
BigQuery's in-memory execution
engine that allows for
super fast queries.
A good way to differentiate
between the two
is that BI Engine
Reservation allocates
memory for intelligent caching,
while standard reservations
allocate compute, or slots.
If you want to learn
more about BigQuery,
check out the rest
of our playlist
and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel
on YouTube for
other great content.
Look out for our next episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight,"
and remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]